pour cette semaine pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas du tout je suis premier
c'était la Fashion Week alors c'est le
Petit Paris qui se retrouve car en soi
on va même plus rouler hein et puis
voilà alors il se réunissent et puis
c'est des gens qui vont porter des robes
qu'on pourra jamais mettre ou des
pantalons ça coûte très cher ils sont
entre eux ils se parlent c'est super
voilà mais bon ça s'appelle la Fashion
Week et donc il y a plein plein de de
modèles et donc du coup sur une petite
idée que tu rigolote c'est la Fashion
Week à Paris l'occasion de revenir sur
les pics look des chroniqueurs je
promets que chaque photo est vrai à la
quelques années mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a un moment donné on a tous pensé qu'on
était à la mode et le problème de la
mode c'est que ça se démode regardez
quelques chroniqueurs alors ça c'est
Benoît
[Musique]
après là c'est quand j'ai gagné le
premier chignon de Bourgogne au milieu
très très fier
et la troisième
c'est important quand même
alors on change de génération
[Rires]
j'avais donné une autre photo à la base
où on voyait ma culotte c'est un un look
très raté ma culotte on pouvait pas le
passer et j'ai mis ce look là parce que
le jour où j'ai porté cette tenue il
m'avait terminé maintenant on avait
terminé en me disant mais mes chéries
enfin pourquoi tu as été avec une
omelette au Festival de Cannes
ça passe attention la troisième ah on
fait un petit sol dans le temps euh
attention Isa pas du tout c'est qui ah
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour qu'il soit raide parce que mes
vrais cheveux parce que
moi non
Caméra café
ou pas du tout et il reste encore vas-y
envoie
[Applaudissements]
je suis là je suis là c'est Mathieu je
suis là
mais ça attends pardon c'est pas le pire
look si si c'est pire look mais c'est
qu'en fait c'est arrivé deux trois ans
elle est pas vieille cette photo c'est
dans mon bureau et en fait j'étais là au
Maroc et j'étais faire coiffer
le lendemain à Paris et j'avais besoin
de me faire couper très vite il y a un
mec marocain un peu bourré qui m'a
appris la tondeuse et qui a fait péter
la tondeuse là et donc il y a un énorme
trou là et pendant 10 minutes le mec a
fait bon on fait quoi et je sais pas tu
t'excuses
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est vrai que voilà j'étais dans un
dans une caravane
comme ça
du camping
je parle pas avec une patate chaude dans
la bouche mais là c'est vrai que c'était
voilà j'avais fait chaussettes
claquettes il paraît que c'est la mode
maintenant
voilà c'est qui c'est Maxime je vais 18
ans Harry Potter tu t'es en terminale et
on faisait une spéciale un peu Harry
Potter et on s'était déguisé comme ça et
du coup et du coup vous savez quoi on
avait rien
un petit côté Grégory Lemarchal je
trouve bah oui mais oui oui en tout cas
merci
tout le temps de joker partout